[Musique]
le dicton à la sainte catherine tout
bois prend racine c'est donc tout
naturellement ce 25 novembre que le
conseil départemental a choisi de
remettre leurs lots aux 465 gagnants du
concours de l'arbre de la sainte
catherine cette année ce sont des
pommiers hautes tiges de variétés
anciennes qui ont récompensé les haut
rhinois associés à l'opération les
associations d'arboriculteurs qui ont
animé les 31 points de distribution
c'est bien souvent dans un froid
saisissant parfois agrémentés de gouttes
de pluie que les heureux gagnants sont
venus chercher leurs arbres
même si il ne fait pas bon être un chat
dehors la fin novembre c'est la bonne
période pour planter des arbres aussi
implanté au printemps mais si on plante
au printemps il faut beaucoup arrosé
parce qu'après il ya la chaleur qui
arrivent il ya la chaleur qui arrive et
il faut beaucoup plus arrosé la sainte
catherine il est de tradition de planter
des arbres est là depuis 16 ans le
conseil départemental du rhin dans le
cadre de ses actions en faveur de
l'environnement et du développement
durable propose des arbres fruitiers à
hautes tiges haut rhinoise et haut
rhinois c'est ainsi que depuis 16 ans ce
sont près de quarante six mille arbres
fruitiers à hautes tiges qui ont été
distribués les haut rhinois et qui sont
allés rejoindre nos vergers
depuis 16 ans l'opération rencontre un
franc succès cette année petit plus les
associations ont profité de la remise
des arbres pour donner un cours
d'arboriculture conseils sur la taille
la plantation l'entretien des arbres
mais aussi sur la valorisation des
fruits l'initiation se veut complète une
façon s'assurer que ses 465 pommier
seront promis à leur destin nous en
profitons et en particulier à partir de
cette année pour initier les haut
rhinois et les haut rhinoises à
l'arboriculture commentait un arbre
comment planter un arbre parce que ça
aussi c'est important savoir planter un
arbre on s'est rendu compte que ya
quelques
inquiétudes vont des arbres qu'on a
distribués ces dernières années qu'ils
sont en mauvais état qu'ils ne poussent
pas bien
donc notre objectif c'est de faire un
cours pour expliquer aux gens comment
planter un arbre il faut pas juste les
mettre en terre effectivement il faut
tailler les racines il faut la faire le
rafraîchir rafraîchir les racines mais
38 eur l'attacher et puis la rosée et le
traité un peu mais avec des produits bio
alors oui il a raison de
le choix des variétés proposées pour le
concours ne doit rien au hasard
ces arbres fruitiers hautes tiges
constituer les vergers entourant les
villages haut rhinois ayant peu à peu
disparu au profit d'autres variétés le
paysage du département s'est modifiée
mais aussi sa biodiversité les arbres
présentant de nombreux avantages pour
accueillir des espèces animales
l'environnement ce sont ces la nature ce
sont les paysages et ce sont aussi les
insectes et la faune qui va s'y nicher
dans les arbres fruitiers à hautes tiges
on a des insectes on a des huppes on a
des chouettes qui viennent se réfugier
et donc notre action d'arbres fruitiers
hautes tiges va dans ce sens là la mise
en valeur la préservation de la faune et
de la flore et ses arbres sont des
arbres à hautes tiges puisque ces arbres
aux tiges sont très peu planté de nos
jours les gens plantent des arbres
beaucoup plus petit mais du point de vue
environnemental c'est très important de
garder des arbres hautes tiges puisque
pour repos pour les oiseaux et pour les
variétés qui sont dessus c'est quelque
chose
d'indispensables de conserver ce
patrimoine et pour le paysage aussi
la question des paysages est importante
dans le haut rhin dévaler des vosges à
la plaine d'alsace en passant par le
piège viticole c'est cette grande
richesse qui fait tout le charme du
territoire mais cette diversité n'est
pas là que pour le plaisir des yeux en
toile de fond c'est aussi la grande
richesse des différents écosystèmes qui
l'habite dont il est question ainsi que
la pérennité des différentes activités
humaines qui ont contribué à façonner
ses paysages le conseil départemental
investi tous les ans 10 millions d'euros
dans le domaine de l'environnement alors
que ce soit au niveau du domaine de
l'eau on est présent depuis la source
jusqu'à la rivière mais également
justement sur ces aspects
d'environnement paysager où on les
actions sont rassemblées dans une
opération qui s'appelle légère plan c
les plans de gestion de l'espace rural
et périurbain donc ce qu'un surtout
voulu faire avec ces opérations c'est
remettre tous les acteurs du territoire
autour d'une table pour que tout le
monde se parle et pour colonne est un
aménagement harmonieux de
l'environnement et après le département
donne des petits coups de pouce pour
justement qu'on puisse mettre en place
de ce dispositif
si tout le monde est bien acteurs de
l'environnement qu'on réussit vraiment
avoir un paysage de qualité mais aussi
un environnement de qualité c'est chacun
avec ses petits gestes qui va apporter
quelque chose à cette construction on ne
peut pas avoir juste les institutionnels
qui font quelque chose sinon en fait on
n'arrive à rien il faut à tout prix
qu'on ait un d'élan de tout le monde
un enjeu environnemental fort y compris
pour nos arboriculteurs amateurs nous
sommes maintenant au verger école à
guebwiller ici la société des
arboriculteurs et bouilleurs de cru
dispense tout son savoir aux gagnants du
concours sur la question des produits
phytosanitaires
leur position est très ferme nous notre
principe c'est de ne plus utiliser de
produits chimiques donc ça on le fait
depuis quelques années déjà ouvert des
écoles et donc ça marche très bien donc
ya pas de raison que chez un particulier
ça ne fonctionne pas après chez des
professionnels le problème est peut-être
un peu différent nous c'est une année on
n'a pas de récolte c'est pas une
catastrophe m
[Musique]
empire et pommiers s'ils sont bien
entretenus et cultivé avec amour
donneront leurs premiers fruits cinq à
six ans c'est certainement un peu long
quand on est habitant aller chercher ses
pommes au supermarché mais comme le
disait voltaire cultiver son jardin est
bien plus gratifiant c'est des arbres
qui vieillissent très bien ils peuvent à
dire des pommiers quand ils sont bien
taillée parce que une taille 10 ans a
prolongé la vie de l'arbre en fait
puisque on l'entretient au ramen la
structure ont déjà créé une structure
qui ce qui est solide en fonction de la
taille de formation et donc ça narvik un
arbre qui vieillit très bien un arbre ou
tiji ou de mytischi peut atteindre son
temps facilement quoi planter rana un
choix d'avenir de quoi s'assurer que vos
petits enfants ne soient pas en manque
de confiture